les adolescents passerait plus de sept
heures par jour le nez rivé à un écran
ça c'est en moyenne ça vous surprend
probablement pas si vous avez des
adolescents à la maison certains passent
beaucoup plus de temps les adultes aussi
un les parents sont pas toujours de bons
exemples il ya l'entreprise les belles
combines qui vous propose cette semaine
de relever défi 5 à 8 dominique barlet
ch qui est des belles combine est avec
nous bonjour bonjour vous êtes
enseignant faut dire de formation vous
avez cinq enfants un de moins de 8 ans
que le délit si un studio derrière c'est
quoi ils regardent trop la télévision
trop les écrans c'est ça qui vous a
incité à lancer ce défilé en fait ben
oui c'était devenu un peu une habitude
je sentais qu'il y avait vraiment un
intérêt assez prononcé pour les écrans
surtout pour la plus petite
étrange que cela puisse paraître qui
avait deux ans à l'époque qui demandait
beaucoup beaucoup le téléphone ou
l'écran pour jouer puis je me suis rendu
compte
je me suis moi-même interrogé sur ma
propre consommation d'écran en fait et
je me suis demandé si j'étais un bon
modèle et c'est vraiment de l'autre la
réflexion
je crois que je ne l'était pas tant que
ça en fait pas que j'étais toujours sur
un écran métier gestionnaires de réseaux
sociaux pour mon entreprise
j'avais souvent le téléphone à la main
parce que je voulais toujours sa mort
est-ce que la dernière publication fin
d'année donc j'étais souvent dérangé
j'ai décidé je me donnais des filles 5 à
8 3 heures heure à laquelle les enfants
sont à la maison avec nous le sait les
trois heures à la ferme et rémy donc des
échanges mais vous l'avez faire j'avais
fait pendant combien de temps on le fait
pour une semaine ce qui a bien
fonctionné a très bien fonctionné
je pense qu'il est plus difficile pour
moi que pour eux ils sont jeunes quand
même j'ai pas des ados bon qu'est-ce que
vous avez constaté comme changement mais
en fait les temps qu'on avait à discuter
aussi le fait qu'ils étaient davantage
tournés vers leurs jouets
ce qui est très important aussi donc
vraiment plus de temps plus de temps
pour faire plein de trucs on
al'impression on est débordés comme
parents puis quand on coupe les écrans
il ya comme du tas qui ait pas vraiment
certains diront en train de devenir
c'est pas de jeunes qu un problème de
santé publique et les optométristes qui
le disent de plus en plus de
spécialistes
qui vont soulever des problèmes de liens
sociaux entre les gens les enfants qui
passent plus de deux heures par jour
auraient de moins bonnes capacités
cognitives selon certaines études
c'est préoccupant c'est très préoccupant
je pense que c'est justement ce que ça
cette campagne de sensibilisation là
c'est à dire aux parents ok il faut
s'arrêter premièrement faire une pause
constatée
c'est quoi notre consommation d'écran à
nous comme famille mais aussi arriver à
donner des repères à nos enfants je
pense est capable de réglementer les
écrans la maison on les utilise qu'un
qu'est ce qui permit combien de temps
c'est je pense est très important de le
faire au même titre qu'on veut leur
donner des repères en lien avec
l'alimentation par exemple j'entendais
une collègue semaine par l'un de ses
enfants active pas d'écran avant de
gérer vous pas d'écran ce soit vraiment
essayé de l'imiter c'est pas évident on
voit donc pour selon l'angela le temps
en moyenne que les gens consacrent ou
qui devraient consacrer la
donc il ya plusieurs directions de santé
publique qui disent que les enfants de 2
à 4 ans ne devrait pas passer plus d'une
heure par jour devant un écran
après quatre ans se tend de devrait pas
dépasser deux heures mais bon la réalité
c'est souvent davantage
on dit que c'est un problème de santé
publique c'est en train de le devenir du
moins est-ce que vous avez approché les
ministères de la santé d'éducation pour
justement peut-être appuyer ces et fils
à l'abri des faits c'est une deuxième
édition cette année la première été
lancée très rapidement suite au
documentaire by d'alexandre tarifaire
c'était comme vraiment une prise de
conscience pour moi je me suis dit ok on
a des jeunes enfants faut faire de la
prévention
là on en est à la deuxième édition
on est très heureuse de voir que les
gens embarquent que les parents veulent
tenter le défi donc est vraiment une
conscientisation qui se fait je pense
que pour une troisième édition ça se
pourrait être vraiment intéressant de
dire ok on va les chercher les
organismes on va chercher des
associations on ira voir les écoles je
pense que c'est important que le message
passe avec que le défi de vienne
peut-être un défi à relever dans toutes
les écoles et que ça vienne mais
peut-être même des enfants qui le
propose comme ça ça peut vraiment faire
une différence
dans le développement des relations oui
parce qu'effectivement c'est drôle parce
que quand on se met à parler à nos
enfants puis à leur dire que c'est
important
c'est souvent une qui vont nous faire la
remarque de maman est encore sur ta
tablette tout est encore sur ton
téléphone ils sont quand même assez
ouais je pense que quand on les
sensibilise après on constate qu'il ya
des compagnies entre autres dont pas
nommé à différentes compagnies
cellulaires qui ne montrent combien de
temps qu'on utilise telle ou telle
application d europe commencent à
sembler sensibilisation semble que le
pas contre courant aux tablettes et plus
ou moins c'est pas tant le temps non
plus con con ça que c'est pas qu'on
passe des heures et des heures c'est
qu'on est toujours sollicité par des
notifications par on sait si ce qui est
le pire en fait ça nous occupe
énormément je rappelle donc défi 5 à 8
qui a relevé cette semaine alors
dominique bernès merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec moi aujourd'hui je suis certain
que ça va susciter des discussions en
famille en fin de semaine merci beaucoup
merci